[Música]
a fome violência poluição falta de
moradia corrupção família desestruturada
falta de dinheiro crise dívidas
sobrecarga falta de tempo insatisfação
pessoal insatisfação profissional como
se resolve tudo isso quem resolve
você conhece alguém capaz e que está
resolvendo esses problemas e você é
capaz de resolver alguma coisa dessa
pode ser que tenha passado na sua cabeça
que a responsabilidade de tudo isso é do
governo de algum grupo que tem mais
dinheiro de algum especialista
mas e nós não fazemos parte desses
grupos específicos
a gente tem um compromisso de em busca
da sociedade que a gente deseja
nós somos é causa de muitos desses
problemas e também somos parte da
solução
eu resolvi ser uma resolvedora de
problema pra mim hoje é mais natural
mirim deparar com alguma dificuldade e
certificar que tem uma solução eu
consiga enfrentar ela então quando
algumas pessoas vêm falar pra mim que
alguma coisa impossível não dar desistir
eu penso o que existiu essa história de
resolver problemas começou em 2011
quando eu entrei na faculdade e no curso
de administração na primeira semana os
calouros participam de uma série de
palestras em uma dela é o centro
acadêmico
médico empresa janeiro começaram a falar
e eles disseram que o curso de
administração é o que é o curso em que
mais ingressos alunos o curso que mais
lança é os irmãos no mercado de trabalho
é o primeiro lugar em entrada e saída
eu sabia que meu curso na era popular na
época tinha aquela frase a 5 de
administração em casa se no brasil e tal
mas eu não sabia que ele era o primeiro
e aquilo me deixou um pouco a angústia a
água porque meu deus quanta gente
competindo comigo não tinha me ligado
nisso e ali eu decidir eu voltei
diferente fez com que eu realmente
realmente me do acidente a carga
compromisso que eu assumi a que eu
pegasse aquela missão da atividade que
estava em mãos e eu tinha que cumprir
ela a minha família ela na época da
faculdade costumava dizer que era em que
então estava muita moda na tabela na
faculdade san antonio a rua das modas
que eu inventei que para eles era muito
diferente eles aqui lidar com bastante
paciência vai participar do movimento
empresário então pra quem conhece e era
uma típica empresária júlia e participar
de todos os eventos eu passava todos os
dias trabalhamos na empresa eu viajava
no final de semana eu planejava é
preocupada com capuz membros da j
mas tudo isso porque estava cumprindo a
missão que o movimento empresa júnior
trazia ele falava que é o mej ele está
ele formava pessoas capaz de transformar
o brasil eu queria transformar o brasil
queria formar outras pessoas que estavam
no brasil
depois disso eu ingressei no estágio
numa grande empresa e depois de um tempo
fiquei também agoniada por que eu não
tava mudam do mundo nenhum sentado
naquela mesa que estava então fazendo
nem cócegas e aí eu pensei é o lugar que
eu tava é decidir não ir para o banco
não entra uma outra grande empresa mas
ele o terceiro setor e eram pra
novidade ali pro pessoal conhecido na
época porque quem faz a administração
sabe nossa vai trabalhar em uma grande
empresa vai empreender vai para um banco
não não vou pra esses lugares e há seis
anos eu faço parte da cide brasil uma
organização que tem a missão de
construir uma sociedade mais inclusiva
da pessoa com deficiência
lá na seed eu sou eu entrei como
estagiário e hoje eu sou diretora de
projetos e boa parte do meu tempo
despendendo encontrando soluções
se eu não encontro eu tenho que
incentiva a minha equipe meu time a
encontrar soluções ou que a gente
encontre outras pessoas que possam nos
ajudar nessa então todo dia a gente
pensa em como quebrar as barreiras que a
pessoa com deficiência tem na sociedade
e diversas coisas a gente enfrenta coisa
é você tem pessoas com deficiência em
extrema exclusão ou que elas não
participam de rotina sociais como as
nossas que para a maioria da gente é
comum como ir ao cinema e à praia sair
de casa e isso está acontecendo com ela
a seed faz questão de ir atrás de outras
pessoas e de fazer essa realidade mudar
aquelas para quem essa pessoa seja
incluída socialmente ea instituições que
desenvolvem as pessoas com deficiência
que estão em crise e precisa de alguma
ajuda no rh o mate na captação de
recursos o que querem expandir quer
aumentar seu impacto
a gente também está lá junto pra fazer
com que os sonhos dela se torne
realidade e ao longo desse tempo de da
cide do meu trabalho no no terceiro
setor
eu percebi que há pessoas que resolvem
problemas e há pessoas que ficam
paralisados ou que responsabilizam os
outros para resolver os problemas é e os
problemas dos outros não é dela e aí o
que eu quero analisar hoje com vocês o
que essas pessoas resolvedores de
problemas tem pra gente disseminar esse
aumentar o nosso time de desenvolvedores
de problemas e algumas características
que
eu notei e trago aqui pra vocês são de
pessoas que cruzaram seu caminho durante
a seed e que fizeram realmente a
diferença que são resolvedores de
problemas
o opa bom
o primeiro é o paulo
muito sorridente ótimo de conversar
diria que ele é um bom empreendedor
embora não fale não não considere nessa
característica dele tem 40 anos
paralisia cerebral ou seja uma parte do
dopado mas o corpo dele é limitado dos
movimentos e tem uma deficiência
intelectual
o fato é que o pablo ele queria resolver
um problema dele que estava incomodando
ele queria ter mais autonomia pra ele e
vip alguns lugares na cadeira de rodas
ele precisava da disponibilidade de
outras pessoas para levar ele pra cá pra
lá e e essas pessoas geralmente elas
diziam ser um pouco daqui a pouco a
gente vai oferecer eu posso e palavras
de paulo paciência é um dom e eu não
tenho então pago foi o incentivo de uma
voluntária que trabalhou 15 dias na
instituição que ele frequenta e que foi
uma ponte feita pela seed
ele decidiu comprar uma cadeira
motorizada para que a autonomia dele
fosse real
e aí começaram os desafios como comprar
onde compra quanto vai custar como eu
vou pagar a primeira idéia foi fazer uma
vaquinha que arrecadou nem metade do que
precisava
paulo poderia ter parado por aí mas a
vontade dele é muito maior então
começando com a sua mãe eles viram a
possibilidade de fazer um financiamento
e conseguir pagar e comprar a cadela a
cadeira em pai né parcelado adiante
alguns anos mas era a viabilidade que
eles tinham e foi feito então a cadeira
começou a ser realmente um sonho
realizado mas e agora como pagar o
combinado entre a mãe eo padrasto foi
que ele é responsável pelas suas telas
como queria arranjar
mais uma vez as conexões foram poderosas
e o padre família aproveitaram as idas e
vindas do pai que é caminhoneiro e
trazia é constantemente pacotes de
farofa os bem deliciosas dos sinais por
sinal ele começou a ver se o conhecido
queria se o pessoal da instituição
gostaria de comprar um vizinho e deu
sete na primeira tentativa de venda ele
levou nove e ainda criou uma lista de
espera
e hoje ele tem um grupo não sabe quem é
quem quiser fazer encomenda pode fazer
ele vende os vizinhos ele vende pela
instituição evidente que os amigos e
tudo isso ele podendo ir e vir com a
cadeira motorizada dele paulo disse para
luke o impossível é a gente que faz a
gente que escolhe o que é possível eo
que é impossível
ele disse que se a gente quer fazer
alguma coisa a gente vai encontrar
dificuldades mas a gente consegue paulo
tem muita vontade e ele teve pessoas ao
redor através de conexões fizeram
acontecer
ele conseguiu resolver o próprio ele
está mais perto da autonomia bom
a outra pessoa que é um típico
resolvedor de problemas é o rubinho
rubens é professor de matemática e já
deu aula no estado na universidade é e
ele faz questão de que a aula dele seja
boa e que os alunos gostem da ordem e aí
já tem um grande desafio é por que fazer
com que os alunos gostem de matemática e
aprendam aí não é essa eu quero ver
também o que ele fazia isso ele ensinava
de um jeito muito diferente esses
realmente gostava e aprendiam cola dele
eis que em alguns momentos da vida de
professor rubem ele e dois alunos com
deficiência visual no começo então o
aluno ele teve lá no colégio e outro na
universidade como ele iria ensinar
matemática para essa pessoa
vocês aprenderam matemática como
provavelmente com a lousa o quadro o
quadro negro é e ap o professor lá
mostrando como faz o x1
a trigonometria e tudo muito visual
provavelmente não foi assim que eu
aprendi e aí é uma pessoa que não está
enxergando como vai compreender a
matemática desta forma rubens
conversando com os alunos eles falaram
que não estavam aprendendo e ele ficou
muito incomodado mas ele viu nesse
problema uma grande oportunidade e ele
prometeu que o aluno eu vou dar um jeito
de fazer você aprender matemática na
universidade é uma complexidade maior
assim eu não entendo muito bem de
matemática mas é algo como divisão de
pollino nomes e daí tem mais os gráficos
resultantes das equações e enfim quando
vou vencer essa promessa para o aluno
ele não fazia ideia o que inventar
vi que ele ia modificar o jeito de
ensinar para que ele aprendesse a
matemática mas com muita criatividade e
algumas associações e lhe deu um jeito é
ele utilizava balas salgadinho caneta
elástico ele encontrou uma chapa numa
loja de construção que poderia ser um
plano cartesiano ele transformou toda a
matemática em algo tangível então aluno
conseguia tocar e conseguir fazer as
operações realmente com objetos e aquilo
tudo passou a fazer muito sentido e
neste momento a face inteira estava
prendendo matemática não só o grupo não
só aluno com deficiência visual todo
mundo estava compreendendo a matemática
rubens ele poderia ter falado para a
diretora para a coordenação que olha não
dá pra dar aula própria esse aluno ou
ele poderia simplesmente continuar dando
aula do jeito dele né final ele o
professor e ele é assim ensina ou ele
poderia ter colocado uma outra pessoa
pra sentar junto com o aluno para fazer
dupla para que ele resolva os exercícios
ali pra ele mas não como ele pensou nos
outros alunos pensou no aluno com
deficiência visual ele teve muita
criatividade ele fez um problema uma
grande oportunidade de ensino
hoje aqueles materiais muito simples e
fizeram aquele aluno entender a
matemática virou um material didático em
que conheci reconhece
sido intensa internacionalmente se chama
multiplano e rubis é um dos 50 melhores
professores do mundo
bom e é aí que está a falha crítica das
pessoas que resolvem problemas
elas são elas têm uma uma grande vontade
elas têm por perto pessoas e elevam a
capacidade dela
então quem vocês têm aí do lado de vocês
que fazem vocês também transformar em
que puxam vocês pra cima que lidam com
positividade com essas conexões que
vocês fazem quando você está com algum
problema vocês olham simplesmente no que
vocês estão passando você consegue
enxergar o próximo ou se consegue
enxergar o que o outro está passando pra
tentar ajudar é eu convido vocês a
pensar em se vocês puderem resolver um
problema hoje vocês morrem de vontade de
resolver qual seria
se vocês tivessem um pouco mais alguns
desses ingredientes um pouco mais de
criatividade e se exercitar o seu
cérebro para pensar diferente quando
está com pessoas positivas olhar um
outro ser que você não conseguiria
resolver esse problema o professor no
curso que eu fiz de inovação social ele
disse as pessoas acham que têm menos
recursos do que elas realmente tem um
recurso financeiro é força é capacidade
e coragem
então a gente se subestima mas na
verdade a gente tem a gente pode muito
mais do que a gente acha que pode então
pega esses para esse problema que vocês
estão morrendo de vontade de resolver
coloque um pouco mais livre ingredientes
só não saibam que vocês podem seja um
pouco mais rubens seja um pouco mais
falo e faço acontecer e aí qual é o
nosso próximo problema ser resolvido
muito obrigado
hum
[Aplausos]
[Música]